We now begin chapter two which asks
the question, what does a patient,
it's a very interesting question.
We're going to look for answers
from a number of different angles.
The first of which is the
ancient history of patients.
We've all evolved events that happened
long ago continue to have consequences
for medicine.
Here are a few of them.
Asymmetric division is something that
happened in bacterial cells more than 3
billion years ago and that created the
condition for the evolution of aging and
probably also for the
maintenance of the germline.
Yeah,
stem cells are a great idea.
They evolve to repair a multicellular
organisms when multicellularity originated
sometime between one and 2
billion years ago. However,
they are pre adapted
to become cancer cells.
They contain some of our
vulnerability to cancer.
Retro viruses inserted into a protal
immunoglobulin gene about half a billion
years ago,
500 million years ago,
and that started the evolution of
the Vertebra adaptive immune system.
Highly invasive placentas evolved in
the shared ancestor of Orangutans,
gorillas, chimpanzees, and humans
about 15 million years ago.
They are associated with Preeclampsia,
which is dangerously high maternal blood
pressure during pregnancy and with the
risk of metastatic cancer.
So you can see that events occurring
between 3 billion years ago and 15 million
years ago continue to have
implications for medicine.
So let's begin to unpack these.
We're going to return to
these events in more detail.
When we discuss aging cancer,
adaptive immunity and parent offspring
conflicts over parental investment.
So first asymmetric division. This is
the condition for the evolution of aging.
The idea is that if in division one cell
can be given the newer parts and the
other cell of the older parts,
the cell lineage with the older parts
will die out and the cell lineage with the
newer parts will persist.
This mechanism has been confirmed in a
bacterium eco lie that appears to divide
symmetrically.
It turns out it does not and it can
explain the survival of the germ lines is
the origin of life.
Yeah.
If division we're perfectly symmetrical,
then it would be impossible for selection
to distinguish between the mother and
the daughter cell.
They would both look identical.
Both would be equally intact or equally
damaged and the reproductive payoff from
improving the maintenance of
both would be equal. However,
as soon as the reproductive payoff of
maintenance becomes smaller in the mother
cell than in the daughter,
the mother reproduced,
the daughter has not yet reproduced.
The mother has the older parts of the
daughter has the newer parts than aging
will evolve as a cost of
reproductive performance,
so selection will improve the cell
that has more payoff in terms of future
reproduction.
Yeah.
Let's take a look at this in eco lie.
Here you can see the old
poles on the cell are in red.
The new polls are in blue as
it goes through cell division.
This becomes an old pole sell.
This becomes a new poll sell.
This sequence here leads to a new
poll sell for at least two divisions.
This one has been an old pool
sell for at least two divisions,
and if we follow this through, you can
see a sequence of divisions over here.
These are how long
those lineages survived.
You can see there's variation
building up on the x axis.
Here we have the consecutive number
of old or new poll cell divisions.
On the y axis we have the normalized
growth rate and you can see that the ones
with the new polls are growing faster
than the ones with the old poles and their
advantage is getting larger and larger.
The ones with the old Poles are
diverging and dying off faster.
The more old poles accumulate.
The second ancient vulnerability
in patients is stem cells.
Stem cells originated with
multicellularity there a great innovation,
but they have characteristics
that predispose them to cancer.
They retain the potential to
differentiate and move that adapts them,
pre adapts them to a cancerous lifestyle.
Yeah,
there are stem cells that are all over
the body that are positioned to replace
cells that were out in our discarded
it, particularly in bone marrow, lungs,
intestine and skin.
Those are the tissues in which
malignant cancer is most frequent.
The next ancient innovation that continues
to have medical consequences is the
evolution of the immune system.
Adaptive immunity was acquired
about 500 million years ago.
Here is a portion of the tree of
life showing the vertebrates up here.
And this is the transition between
Cephalic chordates and ag Nathans.
So these would be lampreys
and hagfish and stuff.
Little coordinates are lancets
and fee oxys, things like that.
And at this point,
a virus inserted itself into
a protocol immunoglobulin gene and it
brought with it transpose on machinery and
that is what allows lymphocytes to
generate diverse antigen receptors to
recognize and to repel antigens.
So that didn't come fully formed.
It required subsequent evolution.
But it's interesting that we got part
of our ability to resist viruses from
essentially a virus and transpose them.
Okay.
So the adaptive immune system evolved
at that point with the invasion of a
transposable genetic element.
This is the transposable genetic element.
This is the immunoglobulin gene here,
the transpose ace gene inserted into
the middle of that immunoglobulin gene.
It can be recognized by the fact that we
can see this particular sequence in the
receptor gene and the transpose ace
jeans are now on separate chromosomes.
So they're called rag one and rag two
subsequent evolution has moved them to a
separate chromosome.
So that event built into the gene,
the machinery that's needed to carry
out the somatic recombination that
generates antibody diversity.
We will be going into that in some
detail when we come to our discussion of
defenses.
Okay.
The next ancient event about 15 million
years ago occurred when highly invasive
placentas evolved.
In the great apes here you
can see a phylogenetic tree
focusing just on the home
and humidity and it shows that we are
most closely related to chimpanzees and
gorillas and then next to
orangutans and the givens.
And we know that in the givens out
here they have shallow invasion of the
endometrium. So when the fetal
cells are forming the placenta,
they do not go as deep into
the endometrium and givens
as they do in the other
great apes and there's minimal remodeling
of the spiral arteries and givens and
there's extensive spiral artery
remodeling in the rest of the great apes.
So this deep extra villous trophoblast
invasion and the extensive spiral artery
remodeling that evolved there gives much
greater control over the maternal blood
supply by the fetus.
You can see here fetal tissue
invading into the endometrium.
There is a spiral arteries are coming
in here and they are being remodeled by
stem cells from the fetus that can
actually go in and control part of the
diameter of the spiral artery.
Yeah,
so when a field stem cell is invading the
intermediary and inserting itself into
a maternal spiral artery,
it is taking partial control of the pipe.
Who's diameter determines the
amount of food that the fetus gets?
Yeah,
that's a morphological example.
With parados spring conflict,
it gives the fetus and advantage early
in life that it pays for with increased
risk of metastatic cancer later in life.
Okay.
Here is the age of some of the
major features of human biology.
In the purpose of this slide is to show
you the different parts of our body
evolved at very different points in time.
We are a mosaic of features
of very different ages,
so metabolism is almost
4 billion years old.
Multicellularity about a billion or
vertebrate adaptive immune system,
about half a billion.
The placenta is about 190 million years
old by Pete Elysium is about 7 million
years old and are hairless
skin are dark skin color,
and our abundance sweat glands
are two to 3 million years old.
So the take home from this is that we
are a mosaic of parts with very different
ages.
Our own history contains quite a bit of
complexity since we split off from the
chimpanzees.
The early hominids included Sahel
anthropics probably already by peatal 7
million years ago.
Australopithecines they flourished between
about four and a half and two and a
half million years ago whereby
peatal they had smaller brains,
they probably were frugivorous ate fruit,
at least four species are known
Australopithecus gave rise to and then
overlapped with pair
Anthropicene. That was about, oh,
from three to 1 million years ago,
roughly several species of per
anthropics in homo coexisted.
So there were times in our recent
history when there were several hominids
living at the same time and interacting
with each other on the planet.
Homo habilis use tools two and a half
to one and a half million years ago,
and homo erectus migrated out of Africa.
So there was a hominid
species that migrated out of
Africa before homo sapiens.
It colonized Asia and Europe.
It used fire,
it cooked it haunted and scavenged.
It was also cannibalistic hand axes from
homo erectus have been found in Spain
from about 800,000 years ago.
Homo sapiens evolved in Africa,
emerged from Africa about a
hundred thousand years ago,
paused in the Middle East for 30 to 50,000
years and then spread out into Asia.
And Europe will go into
this in more detail
in Europe and Asia.
We hybridized with neanderthals and
Denisovans and we may have hybridized with
unknown hominids in Africa within
the last hundred thousand years.
So we can trace that in our genomes and
we can see that people who have been in
Europe have neanderthal genes and
people who remained in Africa do not.
Okay.
So to summarize,
every organism and tree has a history.
Treats have different ages of origin.
Organisms are mosaics of parts that have
existed for different amounts of time.
That has implications for their evolution.
The older the trade,
the harder it probably is to change it.
That's not an absolute,
but it is a tendency,
a trend,
things that can only evolve slowly,
do constrain things that
can evolve more rapidly.
So the old thing set up a framework that
constrains the further evolution of the
more recent, uh, parts of the body.
Some traits of medical significance
are millions or billions of years old.
And every part of the organism and its
history is interacting with many of the
other parts.
So you have to see us as a dynamic
organism existing with a framework of
constraints,
some of which are very ancient.